Hello. Welcome.
It's June 18th, 2026, and we're in
Acton's Model Stream 9.1
on formal verification of active
inference systems in Prism with James
McLair and Gethin Norman. So, thank you
both for joining, and see you for the
presentation. Thank you.
>> Yeah. So,
hello everyone. So, just to
uh
kind of introduce this this is
uh yeah, a paper I wrote, and the slides
for it for um
formally verifying active inference
systems in Prism.
So,
I think to kind of give a good abstract
to the research in this paper, we
we'll kind of start by bridging the kind
of relevant areas. So, for this case,
it's going through the different Markov
decision processes from DTMCs
up to POMDPs and different levels of
abstraction.
We will kind of connect
the kind of formal methods kind of
overview and like
kind of concepts of it with active
inference.
And then we can move on to discussing
how formal methods of Prism kind of
utilize temporal logic to kind of verify
and
uh analyze these systems.
Uh we motivate why these areas are kind
of bring these areas for research are
theoretically valuable and can be
demonstrated. In the case, there's a
kind of theoretical computer science
perspective on this by computational
comparing Prism with active inference.
There's also
a relevant kind of application for
the theoretical cognitive science and
kind of neuroscience in how we formulate
specifying and verifying properties and
active inference.
It's also important just to kind of give
a taste of the results. So,
in a kind of computational perspective,
we have that for the grid-based problem
solving, PRISM outperforms robustly for
small state spaces, whilst active
inference outperforms for larger state
spaces on stochastic-based kind of hyper
parameters for the agents. Uh
I suppose we hope in the following
slides we can kind of clear up what
exactly we mean by small state spaces
and such. And for the verification kind
of perspective on this research paper,
we find that reachability and safety
properties can be verified of active
inference systems in PRISM. However,
there's no kind of constructive
constructive way to
visualize active inference system in
PRISM directly. Um we can
at the end of the slides kind of
outline future directions of research.
So, just to be kind of give a nice taste
of what will be coming up, we'll
introduce who we are, why this is done,
what are from methods in PRISM,
whilst giving the theoretical
background. We can following that, we
can kind of give a good experimental
analysis of
how we conducted our research and how we
did the implementation. Uh we'll do a
quick demo on how PRISM works uh with
the required systems that we
implemented,
the kind of how
how we implement the active inference
experimental runs and how we conducted
the verification step by PRISM,
where we'll conclude with the
experimental results and evaluation of
those results, and also conclusion and
future work.
So, yeah, I think it's kind of good to
give a a nice introduction. So,
I think
why
I conducted this research is I very
interested in just things kind of
related to cognitive science, whether
that could be things like
just psychology and neuroscience. So, I
think I was very very excited to look
into active inference as a as a kind of
research research area. It seems really
really exciting.
Uh
and I thought it was kind of a good way
in my
background in theoretical computer
science and maths to kind of utilize
things like formal methods to in this
case Prism to analyze uh active
inference.
Uh Gefen, would you like to
give a quick introduction to to your
background?
I think you're you're on mute.
>> Sorry about that. So, I'm Gefen at
Norman. I'm a professor in the School of
Computing Science.
So, my background is sort of in formal
methods and in particular
that model checking and that's for
uh slight probabilistic systems. So,
from
our DTMCs up to
stochastic games. And I focused on this
sort of slight with
we've developed slight Prism, which is
one of the leading probabilistic
slight model checkers. And slight
regarding this work, this was very much
led by James. I didn't really know
anything about active inference when
and James came to me and asked if if he
could work in this area and I saw there
was some overlap with what I did and
therefore sort of
that's how slight slight project came in
into being.
So, back to you, James.
>> Okay, good. Thank you.
So,
to start us off before we kind of get
into the the research ideas, I think
it's
I think for the sake of the viewers,
it's kind of good to give a good primer
on kind of what formal methods are and
how Prism is a is a kind of how Prism is
a unique instantiation of formal
methods. So,
a kind of good concise definition I
think I could give for formal methods is
that they're mathematically rigorous
techniques for specification and
verification of computational systems.
So,
it's kind There's kind of three core
principles that connect connect various
formal
model method to the model checkers where
there's some kind of degree of
specification, verification, and
synthesizing. So, by set specification,
this is typically
formally describing properties via some
form of formal logic that should hold in
state-based systems. So, these could be
properties like probability, rewards,
where when we talk about uh
computational systems, we can mainly
describe systems that kind of have
computational aspects of it. So,
this is kind of typically
systems that kind of correspond to
states, the transitions between
different states, labels, uh etc.
Verification
kind of involves the application of data
structures and algorithms to verify
properties of a system. So, depending on
the properties, each will typically have
a unique kind of approach and how it
uses a certain algorithm and how it uses
certain data structures to then output a
property based on that. And finally,
synthesizing is very much about the
formulation of kind of artifacts of the
system that satisfy a property.
So, an artifact in this case is a
concrete object produced by s-
the satisfaction of that specification.
This is very, very abstract, but I hope
we do have lots of kind of cases of and
kind of example cases to kind of make
sense of of these. And it kind of
finishes quite nicely.
The main thing is
in the type of model checking we're
doing, it's probabilistic model checking
based. So, it's the application of
formal methods to tools to allow systems
that exhibit random behavior.
Uh where linked active inference, this
is this can be done via
uh PRISM DPs.
So, like I said, PRISM is a
probabilistic model checking tool.
It's the state transition by where we
try to model computational systems are
encoded in PRISM's unique reactive
module language, where PRISM uses
temporal logic for the for property
specification.
When I mentioned the verification, it
kind of uses specific data structures
and algorithms for
the verification of properties active in
Sorry, PRISM is very much based on
qualitative and quantitative derivation
for on binary decision diagrams and
variants. So, for the Boolean outputs of
where we're kind of looking at
quality-based properties, so that could
be is this true or false, we just use
kind of binary decision diagrams. Whilst
for kind of more
kind of more sophisticated properties
and the quantitative properties, we can
use multi-terminal binary decision
diagrams.
For the sake of this presentation, we
are not going to go super specific into
how the complexities of binary decision
diagrams.
It's just very much all that can be
known is that wherever a property's been
specified, it is in some form kind of
being
uh broken down into these.
And in the example of synthesis where
certain artifacts are kind of
formulated, these are
The PRISM terminology will say
strategies for the kind of people who
know about active inference and other
areas like reinforcement learning
kind of policies kind of overlap kind of
nicely to this.
But Prism is very flexible. So, it's
very much focused on Markov decision
processes for computational systems, but
it also is able to formulate stochastic
games and probabilistic time automata.
It's based on maximizing minimizing kind
of prob- reachability in probabilistic
formulations properties and achieving
kind of rewards. So, this might be
minimum expected time to reach the goal
in the maze, synthesizing strategy that
yields to the minimum expected time. And
it does this by delivering brute force
brute force solutions where importantly
this theoretically means with enough
compute computational power it can kind
of solve uh
yeah, the any of the the formulated
problems.
So, I think getting into the kind of
section of why and why we did this
research. So,
I think what's
at least to
the kind of stated research goals like
active inference is very very very is
very normative based theory. So,
describes what an agent entity should do
to minimize free energy and the
behaviors interpreted through that lens.
The kind of core to my understanding
like the core a core kind of goal of
active inference as with other normative
theories is whether the question of real
systems that actually instantiate the
theory
there's a desire for it to be kind of
have evidence that
is kind of
is is empirically kind of uh cogent in a
in kind of verifiable property specified
uh
basic experiments.
So,
I think the thing that seems very very
potential where formal verification has
a lot of potential in this regard is
that
formal verification can give a way to
close that gap. So, we can ideally
define properties that an active
inference agent should satisfy, whether
this be reachability, policy
convergence, and belief updating.
The novel side of why the intersection
of these two areas is
relevant in in the research senses
active inference is
in its sense a POMDP solver, and it sits
in a kind of a competitive landscape of
various other POMDP solvers.
And in a computational view for POMDPs,
when I say computational, I suppose a
comp
computational complexity kind of
research perspective, we do know that
POMDPs are for fixed time steps in
space, and for infinite time steps are
undecidable.
So, to kind of take it serious as a
solver, we could
there's a a unique kind of perspective
that PRISM can give where
uh
we can kind of formally specify what
correct solutions look like, and whether
active inference can achieve those
correct solutions.
So,
for inspiration papers that kind of help
guide how we can conduct this research,
so PRISM as a formal method checker has
a lot of validity here as has extensive
application of being applied to systems
biology. This is in cases where there's
biological systems that kind of have can
be modeled as kind of state transition
systems, and kind of therefore exhibit
computational-based properties.
There's quite a lot of
cases where it's been applied. A a
specific one that I think I mentioned
here was
the application to kind of DNA walker
circuits,
uh
which uh could kind of verify properties
of how
they kind of the what you call it like
phenomena of kind of DNA walkers, how
they kind of had a computational systems
of them can be verified.
Relevant to kind of this research
paradigm, PRISM has used kind of simple
grid-based POMDPs in the the Keil
binding 1995 paper, which kind of
is a kind of good parallel to
a lot of like the active inference based
grid-based research areas in the vein.
PRISM has also based on research in the
South Korean institute some some
researchers applied PRISM to
reinforcement learning, where there's a
although
in that case it was kind of a a paper
based on Markov decision processes, the
the same process to how they verified
properties in reinforcement learning
context was very much used in the same
vein to active inference.
And there has been cases where PRISM has
been used for psychological
in the base scenarios, so there's a 2025
paper where
kind of there was a a game theory
scenario that was used to kind of um
conceptualize and
and verify psychological kind of base
interactions with different agents.
And I think a very big part is
there's very much a lack of
or lack of kind of extensive research in
applying formal methods to
in the same way PRISM has been used for
DNA walkers, you know, there's not a lot
of research applying formal methods to
the kind of uh computational
neuroscience based
kind of abstractions of
of that in like a systems biology
formulation. So, it seemed like a it
seemed like the kind of all the parts of
this research, whether it's Prism
and verifying
systems
quite Yeah, neuroscience-based systems
kind of seemed all to connect quite
quite well.
So,
we're now going to go into some of the
underlining
I guess maths, temporal logic. So, we're
kind of going to go through the the main
relevant stochastic processes. In this
case, Markov Markov processes that Prism
it can be used under.
Uh we'll kind of interlink how it active
inference relates to these structures,
where we can then introduce temporal
logic and the Prism's verification
machinery.
Uh yeah.
But, a kind of good way to to kind of
get started with this is
I think with all kind of Markov chains,
what can be kind of
I guess regarded as like the most
mathematically simple is that of
discrete-time Markov chains. So,
based on the Markov property, where we
analyze the current state system based
on just information from the previous
one, we can define a DTMC as just a
simple tuple. So, that is having
a finite set of states, an initial
state, a probability transition
function, which encodes the probability
of moving from one state to another
state based on a time-step process, and
a labeling function that assigns each
state a an atomic
composition.
So,
just to kind of give an instantiation of
what this might look like, just so we
kind of leave the the abstract space a
bit, let's just imagine a faulty traffic
light, where we've got set four states,
which is red, amber, green, and
So, and let's say the initial state in
this case is red. So, the probability
transition function will
for each kind of indexed state, so let's
imagine that red is zero going up to
amber being one, green being two, and
fault being the third one.
We can kind of encode the likelihood
transition from one state to next. So,
just to kind of read what this
transition matrix would say. So, red is
to go to red, so that would be zero, but
there's a chance of it going to amber,
in this case very, very high.
But, as this faulty system, there's a
0.005%
chance of it going to faulty,
where a labeling function may be applied
to kind of
reference and kind of
add certain labels to certain states.
So, in this case, red is stop, green's
go, all kind of relative based on the
system.
So,
at least regards to PRISM and kind of
analyzing formal methods of stochas- of
Markov decision processes, important
artifact, let's say, can be We could
talk about our paths, as they represent
possible executions of a discrete-time
Markov chain.
So, by quantifying the probability of
paths, we can kind of formally reason In
the case of where we've got the context
of an agent,
kind of use it visualizing with a DTMC,
we can kind of formally
reason about the agent's behavior. So,
we define that a path in kind of two
ways, where there's an infinite where,
based on how many states it can kind of
go on, or for a finite state, we um we
have a certain endpoint,
where we can define the probability of
of a finite path in this case being
based on the on the shown equation,
uh where we
we will try to kind of There's a lot of
symbols and maths here, but we will try
to kind of
uh
to the best of our ability kind of
describe these in kind of plain English.
So, we have
kind of terminology to denote the last
the last state in the path or of a set
of finite paths and apps. A good
example, kind of going back to the the
traffic light, is let's say an infinite
path could be going from red to green to
amber to red, which goes on
infinitesimally. Whilst we could say in
this case a finite path is maybe when it
gets to fault, where we can then define
the probability of reaching that based
on the aforementioned states. So,
red to orange in this case is there is a
0.9% chance of that, where amber to
fault state, there's a
it's very much just based on the the
shown equation here of
uh
The Everything to mention is PRISM will
encode certain rewards per state. So,
we encode reward structures where
there's the state rewards and transition
rewards. And how we can kind of utilize
this is based on the expected cumulative
rewards of reaching a set of target
states. So, it's kind of the expected
value per
for the value of the state and for the
value of the the transition. So,
if we again apply this to the case of
traffic light,
if we have a state that's faulty, we can
assign it quite a high reward in this
case, and then we can kind of com-
combine that with the the transition,
the expected value of the transitions to
or the cost to reach that fault.
So, now kind of going into more kind of
adding more sophistication to the
the Markov processes. In the case where
if we
at least from the PRISM view, we
or how we define Markov decision
processes very much just adding
non-determinism with upon DTMCs in this
case
where
in the case of a kind of an agent view,
an agent can select an action which
determine the transition distribution.
So, this would just kind of extend the
definition by adding a finite set of
actions. So, I suppose in a kind of in
the case of like a grid view, this might
be just up, down, right, left. I believe
this is very familiar to
uh what active inference has done
research on, where also extends
transition function.
One thing
that
PRISM kind of has its own
kind of formal definition of how to
define policies. It's more regarded as
in being defined as schedules
strategies. This kind of may
It's kind of good to note that this is
kind of different from what might be
defined in the active inference research
space and a kind of reinforcement
learning space. So, in regards to PRISM,
a policy is very much a for the the set
of finite paths, how they map to a
certain probability for a given action.
And
this can kind of be seen as kind of
extending paths for the context of a
Markov decision process as we have that
introduction of non-determinism
where
we also kind of define our terminology
like the set of all states
uh and
if uh
yeah.
And uh finally, kind of getting to what
is kind of very relevant to active
inference is a partially observable uh
MDPs where
I guess from the PRISM view, it's just
adding that kind of influence of
observation. So,
it's the fact that a given agent will
need some form of kind of perception of
its environment. It can't There's a kind
of extra layer to
serving states where
we just add the artifact of just obs in
this case as seen here.
As POMDPs, there kind of needs to be a
kind of connecting to how we can kind of
visual
understand the degree of beliefs per
state.
PRISM makes use of a another structure
which is just a belief MDP where in this
case it kind of introduces
the degree of kind of an agent's kind of
degree of belief per state. This can be
represented by the belief simplex which
is just the continuous space of all
probability distributions. We have an
initial belief.
Uh we have the belief transition
function. So, it's kind of good to note
here that the reduction is exact but
generally intractable as the belief
simplex is kind of continuous and
depending on how large or how many
states or how kind of
precise we are with
the given belief simplex, it could be
computationally intractable to calculate
this.
The final thing
how we use the belief transition. This
is quite a big
a big um
a summation here but it's just kind of
good to show this is how when operating
on or when trying to when PRISM tries to
solve a a POMDP, it will make use of the
belief transition function to understand
how beliefs can are encoded and how the
how taking actions kind of
updates distributions in in this case.
Um
I've I've left some kind of breaks for
this part just in case
there's anything I can clear up or in
case
and Gethan has anything to mention that
I may have missed out on presenting in
these slides. Uh
how are we how are we doing so far in
terms of
going through
kind of background concepts.
If um
>> Also a quick Also a quick quick question
from the live chat.
Ken May wrote,
"Nice presentation.
What's the end goal or objective of the
work?"
>> So,
the end goal objective I think was
in some way to see
I think the two ways were
I think going back to the original slide
where we've got the kind of verification
perspective.
Uh I can kind of go back.
The two goals can be kind of
conceptualized as
kind of
investigating active inference as a
normative theory. So,
ideally one of the goals was what could
PRISM offer active inference in
instantiating the theory in a
as if
in in trying to kind of make it verified
and properly properly specified
where we could try and kind of isolate
properties of active inference. So, in
this case let's say reachability of an
agent from starting position to an end
goal state. Uh the hope was or the hope
is is that um formal methods and PRISM
being a kind of POMDP-based solver could
add research relevancy to that.
Um
and again the kind of second goal was
the analysis of the of competition
complexity. So, it's kind of
I guess if
if
if active inference is kind of based on
the free energy principle, which is very
much about kind of inference where
there's a potential degree of may not
kind of there's no guaranteedness and
how it may reach a kind of goal,
we can kind of compare that to prism,
which is very much based on a brute
force approach where it can kind of
guarantee
more
definitively if say just based on it
being kind of brute force if an agent
can get from a starting position to say
end goal. So, yeah, I I think the goals
were to kind of
see how formal methods in the case of
prism can kind of instantiate
instantiate active inference
as a normative theory and also to kind
of compare
compare active inference as a non brute
force theory in comparison to kind of
prism as a brute force theory and
analyze kind of computational results of
that.
Uh
Hope that's kind of yeah, I hope that's
clear. Um I can kind of go back to
question slide.
Uh
Yeah, so anything else I can I can try
answer.
>> Yeah, we we we we we can ask more
questions. Thank you for that though at
the end.
>> Okay, great.
Yeah.
So,
we have these three slides where we're
going to now kind of
start to kind of bridge active inference
with the aforementioned concepts. So,
like I mentioned before, POMDPs are very
vital
for the
the the kind of concept of active
inference as the generative model.
Typically, it uses
as
I can I I don't want to repeat myself. I
know I can understand this might be kind
of repeated knowledge. So, we have the
ABCD matrices.
we can directly map these to certain
concepts in PRISM. So, there's the
observational model, which is just the
transition coding of a given hidden
state to the observation state. There's
a transition model in this case. There's
a
There's a kind of log preference over
certain observations, and then there's
also the prior observational state over
initial states. So, PRISM and active
inference can have different
different kind of terminologies for
representing these and kind of different
ways of connecting them. Uh
the only thing that active inference
will kind of build on upon this is the
concept in the free energy principle,
which is the variational free energy and
the expected free energy.
So,
yeah, it's very much, again,
so
obviously,
typically and expect in active
inference, the expected free energy,
there's we have the expected free energy
over different policies. This kind of
maps quite in a similar sense to how
PRISM encodes schedules, where it has
the set of all finite paths for a given
action, where in this case
the expected free energy is for
I guess can be in terms of PRISM
terminology, it's less so about
policies, but kind of it relates more to
paths in the sense of it being state
action pairs. Obviously, depending on
how kind of
in-depth
uh the the view is in that regard.
And then, obviously, there's the element
of message passing. So,
at least for the research we did,
it's obviously important to mention
mention variational message passing as
it's important for how a lot of the
concepts of
um
I very much used the the active
inference book to kind of help with my
understanding of
how
active inference use utilized certain
concepts. We uh We made We made heavy
use of the PyMDP Python framework prior
to version 1.0. So, for relevance of
this, we a lot of our active in
when we simulated the active inference
agents, it made use of FPI, so which is
just a iterative belief update system
until
convergence.
Uh
I also included a quick break.
I've
I was I suppose there wasn't as maybe as
much information
uh in that. We can
we could probably move on to the start
of temporal logic. Uh again,
there'll be a lot of kind of math
symbols, but we
I to the best of our ability and suppose
of questions, we can kind of clear up
some some of the kind of concepts.
So,
yeah. So, temporal logic, this is kind
of us getting more kind of
exiting more kind of essentially
probability and
as an area of research and kind of
delving into temporal logic. Uh so,
as we mentioned with the kind of three
principle that defines kind of formal
methods, we have specification,
verification, and synthesis. This is
kind of alluding to to start with to the
specifications when talking about
properties. So,
properties in the sense can be kind of
characterized by a formula, so we have
uh
we have kind of four different kind of
syn
elements of syntax. So, we've got the
propositional formulae, which is just
kind of Boolean combinations of
observations.
Uh we have path formulae, which is the
properties of executed paths.
Uh paths in this case, if we kind of
hearken back to the introductory sides
of the Markov decision process concepts,
that's just a a series of state
transitions
where we have bounded, so
do certain instantiations of
propositional formulae hold within K
steps. By steps, this is kind of very
much within kind of time. And then we
have unbounded, which
um kind of formulae that are not bounded
by time.
And
we also have kind of kind of
higher-order formulae, so we've got kind
of quantitative objectives, which is
this may seem
we will make sure to kind of kind of
showcase kind of uh examples of this
just kind of help with understanding. Uh
but we have three formulae, which is the
instantaneous,
uh
cumulative, and reachability rewards,
where we also have based on these state
formulae.
So,
kind of getting into some let's say
yeah, kind of instances or kind of
examples of using these formulae. Um
if the propositional formulae, let's say
beta for the sake of kind of
not saying huge words.
Uh if it's based on kind of certain
observations, in this case, we've got
stop, go, caution, error, kind of going
back to the traffic light example.
This could be say reachability, for
example,
where in the previous slide we mentioned
this as a state formulae, so
we might have say, what's the
probability of eventually reaching a
state where go holds is at least 0.95%.
So, this again kind of harkens back to
the idea of kind of paths having a
certain probability of reaching a path.
So, if we go say
if each kind of transition has a certain
probability, this is just kind of
specifying a property of how likely
uh what's the probability of this kind
of happening. So, in this case we have
We have other things up up above
reachability, which is safety. So,
what's the probability of reaching a
false state within 10 steps? Is at most
0.1. What's the probability What's the
expected cost?
Uh these are
These are kind of when we talk about
properties in this case, this is how we
can apply temporal logic to mapping each
of these.
With this, we have to kind of in order
to kind of link with the verification
step, we need to kind of formally define
as this is kind of as extending the kind
of realm of temporal logic and kind of
you have formal logic and kind of going
more to kind of quantifiable
computational kind of concepts, we can
encode, say, the proposition that a
state's true as being always true, a
state is a certain observation. That's
it's a an observation event within the
set of all observations and such. This
is just a kind of a good way of kind of
giving semantical meaning to certain
propositions.
We have certain cases for paths, which
can connect the early idea of paths
having certain
probabilities assigned to them in the
set of all path states. We have, say,
for bounded until operation, a certain
beta must be reached within K steps. Uh
and the case with unbounded,
a propositional formula must eventually
be reached while whilst a certain other
propositional formula is also kind of
held at each prior step.
And we have it for rewards, which again
connects the earlier
kind of conceived ideas of reward per
states and per per transition function.
So,
if, say,
the idea of a property of
formulating say an instantaneous reward,
that's just kind of conceiving what is
the accumulative rewards at this given
state.
If
if we uh if we're communitive for
communitive if we're kind of talking
about how many rewards kind of garner
from a certain set from a certain
series of transitions including the
states, we can kind of conceive that as
being related to what is the the reward
of the state in combination with the
transitions to getting up to there.
And then the
or more complicated cases where we have
the reward accumulated, that also just
makes use of
similar communitive rewards accumulation
uh and also includes possibility that if
if that property is never satisfied, it
kind of carries on infinitely. So, based
on that, no concrete reward value can be
conceived.
I can
I think this kind of these set of slides
kind of represent people probably
the most
kind of unique to kind of maybe what's
been presented in some of these
presentations. So, in case I wasn't
clear, I can kind of clear up one
information or get them to kind of help
out with some of the concepts. This
could be a good point to kind of go over
the
the previous slides on temporal logic if
there are if there are any
concerns or questions.
>> One one quick question I have there is
you're you're evaluating spaces of
traces and rollouts for the agents.
How do you deal with
rollouts on the environment side?
You just handle that in terms of the
observation state space?
Or like in this traffic light example,
we haven't really heard about the
traffic lights environment.
>> Uh-huh.
So, it I suppose it depends on
when you say environment, is this kind
of regarding if an environment if
there's kind of lots of
um
non-deterministic aspects of it. So, say
uh just like changes in the environments
in that sense.
Or is it just
>> Yeah, like within a
whether it's within a stationary regime
where it might be accounted for well
just by sweeping over observation
state spaces
or how do you know how how can you or
can you make
strong claims about agents boundedness
without taking environmental
stability into account?
>> I think the
one thing I will say about
Prism is that it's very much it needs to
kind of have
it can kind of struggle to kind of
conceptualize
more and more kind of
complications in like certain So, I
think in order for Prism to kind of
conceptualize kind of more
unpredictability in environments, it
would therefore kind of have to add more
states and kind of make systems more
complicated.
And I think
with that as we all kind of get to
kind of future slides, that just adds
more computational costs. So, I guess to
answer your question and get them to
correct me if any of them
it's more um
it
it's kind of not like say reinforcement
learning or active inference in a sense
where it can kind of deal with surprise
or unpredictability. It's very very very
good for kind of
very well-defined environmental cases.
So,
uh yeah. Uh I guess that Does that kind
of help answer your question?
>> So, if I can add, it sort of
it's like the states encode everything.
So they would encode the environment
state and what and the full
It's like it's like system which is it's
like the limitation of the approach is
that if the full it's like system is
very it's like complicated then
obviously it's hard
it it it it becomes infeasible
to uh represent it. And any unpredictab-
unpredictability or sort of that's then
it's like encoded in the transit in the
probabilistic transition
um it's like function.
So.
So does that make sense?
>> Yeah. Yes, I think we can maybe return
to it. It it often comes up with the
transition function modeling that the
agent could have a given transition
model of the world in its generative
model.
And there can be certain properties, but
of course how the agent thinks the
world's transitions are going to be
may or may not be
how the world transitions actually are.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So that I would say yeah, cuz like
I know active inference has like the
idea of using Dirichlet distributions of
the ABC of the AB and the D matrices for
um kind of
you know, being able to kind of cope
with changes in environments in that
sense. Uh
present doesn't have
I suppose it's
it defines like an idea of rewards uh
but it doesn't kind of have the similar
thing with reinforcement learning where
there's like a a learning kind of
component. It's kind of it's very much
focused on
being very
trying its best to kind of analyze like
relevant states that kind of encompass a
given environment. So
uh
yeah.
>> We're looking to find the optimal it's
like agent. So we so in the model it it
it includes the agent what choices that
the agent could make and then we find
the optimal like choices or the optimal
agent
for a given slot property.
>> So the last kind of set of slides in the
background before we kind of get to the
research directions is we can kind of
talk about how Prism
kind of instant instantiates the kind of
verification and the synthesis
principles of kind of formal methods. We
can only cover what's relevant to the
research. So when we
when we talk about a
when we kind of talk mention like
artifacts of what we're trying to
synthesize, this is like the process of
translating like an informal
specification into formal temporal
logical properties and the Prism model.
So in this case for vacation, given a
POMDP and the state property,
can we decide if POMDP holds for all the
strategies or policies in the set of all
possible strategies or policies.
And for the strategy synthesis, this is
this is kind of more about finding a
certain artifact in this case, policy in
this kind of given for that's property
for the given defined state space.
Does it hold for that
for that case of phi? Just to
give context, phi in this case refers to
either
a probability kind of formula where
for a certain state path and the reward
for the relevant kind of reward formula.
This is where the the verification and
kind of synthesis connection. So
kind of
at least at the start, I kind of ideas
of what this might look like for how it
could be applied to active inferences,
this and this kind of links back to the
previous question I answered with
one of the goals
and it kind of regards to kind of
certain verification possibilities. It
could be something like does an agent
reach a preferred state with sufficient
probability?
Do does the agent's belief state
converge under certain message passing
scheme?
Does the agent kind of select an optimal
policy that minimizes the free energy?
It was kind of propositional formulas
like these that kind of inspired trying
to connect PRISM with active inference
in this case.
And kind of detailing how the
verification and synthesis kind of work
out with the underlining algorithms and
the data structures.
We do make use of kind of verifying
discrete time Markov chains in this case
and this makes
this will kind of
use computations of matrix vector
multiplication.
Uh
We
we can happily kind of go back into
this. This is kind of encapsulating
quite a lot of complicated processes
that go on within PRISM.
Uh But what
needs to be known is that it can based
on these kind of implemented formulas,
it can uh output uh in the case of
kind of of state formulas or reward
formulas path formulas or reward
formulas like a a given output.
The the case for POMDPs of PRISM is a
bit more complicated because it has a
certain approach to how it uses the
belief state simplex.
Uh we can kind of again in some
kind of give more kind of like
context to how this might look for the
research direction. A
the best way I can kind of describe it
is in the same way um
you might have certain resolutions for
like a photo and certain a certain
degree of kind of pixels make something
more clear or or less clear. Uh a good
analogy is how Prism uses a similar
thing for kind of
conceptualizing belief states for a
given
kind of system. So
the
the kind of belief simplex that we apply
value iteration over this uh where
Prism will kind of define a over an
approximation and a under approximation
for a given probability scenario. So
this is like I said
based on a certain grid approach uh
where
if it will kind of iteratively kind of
calculate an over approximation of the
from scenario and then under
approximation where if
to kind of get more information, this
will be kind of reiterated. So if the
bounds are tight, the grid resolution is
increased. This can be kind of thought
of like say 240 uh pic megabytes to like
480 uh pixels is more resolution, so it
means it's like a kind of clearer
understanding of the belief simplex for
a given scenario. A cost of that is it
will be it will be more computationally
expensive to calculate this, but the de-
the kind of degree of clarity over the
scenarios is increased. Uh
But that kind of finishes our background
uh
for any of the watchers, uh
I hope that was clear. Can kind of
understand that a lot of these kind of
concepts can are very very abstract. We
I suppose we hope we can kind of further
connect the dots to how
uh
kind of how we implement these concepts.
So,
uh
we kind of start to kind of lay out the
how we how we can actually
implement and research both these two
areas of active inference and formal
formal verification by PRISM.
So, two big aspects that occurred was we
focused purely on discrete-based
scenarios as opposed to continuous. So,
this a big reason of this is that PRISM
is better able to compute kind of
discrete-based systems uh rather than
continuous.
So, and also the the frame the active
inference framework we used, which was
PyMDP, is also discrete-based. So, it
was kind of for the sake of
kind of a more clearer research
environment, we focused on on this.
A very big aspect of this research was
kind of fundamental to a lot of
formal methods
uh formal method tools, they are unable
to kind of
uh have certain numerical methods for
supporting kind of operations like
differentiation or softmax. So, there
wasn't a way for us to
concretely build an active inference
system in PRISM's formal logic. Uh nor
at time did PRISM kind of support a
similar like library format akin to what
could have been done in Python. Uh we
will kind of go to
we will eventually kind of reach a slide
which talks about our approach to kind
of dealing with this case. Uh
but
based on
kind of focusing back to like the kind
of computational complexity analysis of
the two approaches,
uh
we
it was kind of important for us to focus
on with with that with active inference
as it's a a kind of policy-based
approach, we um
the more
when kind of solving a problem, the more
options for paths, when this case
policies are considered, the more
computations that could be.
Another big aspect of this is obviously
with policies, the more the bigger the
kind of time steps per state action pair
were considered, that could greatly
greatly uh lead to policy explosion,
which could be the computational kind of
downside of of active inference in this
case. Uh and also the fact that as it's
not a brute force-based solution, there
is no guarantee for success in a given
or no guarantee of reaching the optimum
uh case of solving a given uh
problem.
So, in the case of um
PRISM as a probabilistic model checker,
as it is brute force, for smaller state
spaces, there could be more guarantee
for reaching a to find solution for a
a given
a given system.
Uh however, this could get very
complicated and involve a lot more
complications than could be possible for
larger state spaces.
So, regarding the actual environment, so
based on the research of the previous
applications of POMDPs of
analyzing POMDPs in PRISM and in active
inference, we stuck to a grid-based
approach. This is very much used in
active inference, so we thought that
this was a kind of good kind of example
scenario for us to use. So, we used we
kind of had a system of
an agent has to reach a certain goal.
Whenever it reaches that goal, it
randomly spawns in a certain other
location and rinse repeat. So,
uh
we Yeah, this kind of seemed like a very
good way of
comparing the two approaches.
Uh we
Yep.
So, kind of talking about the
experimental setup for
for the active inference, we made use of
the Python-based PiMDP library where we
implemented a kind of Python environment
via PiMDP where we ran our experiments.
We
for the case of research
talking about the certain com- important
kind of hyper parameters from the
computational complexity research view,
we analyzed the time steps for a given
agent agent reaching from its initial
position to achieving the end goal. So,
time steps, this is how long each
experiment went on for in regards to
time steps.
Uh
There's kind of two important parameters
we analyzed from the active inference
space, which was alpha. So,
um
I don't have the certain equation up for
it, but it's um it can kind of be very
much analyzed in the perspective when
it's low, it's very an agent will kind
of go about very habitual-based
processes to reaching its end goal. If
it's very high, it's far more
exploratory. And gamma or precision in
this case,
uh
again,
uh it's kind of as it's related to
calculating the expected free energy, um
if it's kind of low, it kind of
corresponds to agents that make
behaviors on kind of
kind of prioritizing less of
um
kind of optimizing the expected free
energy, which could be kind of
considered more exploratory. Uh however,
high, it's very very focused on
achieving and minimizing its free
energy.
Um and then, obviously for this case,
policy and path length is very important
as the short the longer it can be able
to kind of have a a better horizon for
achieving goals. However, it comes at
the cost of being more computational
having kind of larger mem- memory
impacts of having calculated all the
different policies and
for the sizes and for the amount of
them. Where the important kind of output
variables for this are the episode
count. So, in this case, how many times
did the agent go from start position to
the end position?
What was like the peak memory
for these for these kind of research
runs? And the time per episode. So, this
is I think the actual
uh I think real time to kind of
calculate this.
So, for
the Prism side of things, uh
we mentioned previously grid resolution
can be kind of conceptualized as how
precise and how many belief states can
be used for when solving the POMDP. So,
again, a good analogy was kind of
similar to photo resolution. Lower kind
of means it's a less grainy picture of
of what's trying to be identified,
whilst higher is kind of more kind of
more concept
more information on how it
how it can be pictured.
So, smaller means kind of less
precision, but it's computationally
easier, whereas higher is
allows like the brute force to kind of
go through more cases of certain beliefs
over the state space, but it requires a
lot more power. So,
the kind of important outputs for these
are time, so how long it takes to kind
of run these Prism-based experiments. It
might never finish based on how many how
many state spaces there are and how many
belief points needs to propagate over.
The estimated value in this case is the
final kind of
kind of reward objective of an agent
reaching a state. So, with Prism, it's
important to note based on the two
identified properties we talked about
earlier, which was the kind of
minimum probability of reaching
somewhere and the kind of final expected
value,
you can just by simply calculating the
expected value, it kind of inadvertently
also kind of
does the same calculations for the
minimum probability of reaching a end
goal.
And um
the final thing to kind of analyze is
the relative error. So, this kind of
corresponds to the the kind of grid
resolution and kind of that idea of
there being an under approximation and
an over approximation, this is the kind
of calculation of the the difference of
the over approximation and the under
approximation when solving a certain
step. We state
And kind of to answer back that question
we were talking about with the
how we went about kind of going about
verifying properties in active
inference. As PRISM can support softmax,
it can support the kind of required
calculus operations that kind of go
about in a given message passing scheme,
we took heavy inspiration for what was
done with the reinforcement learning
paper where I applied PRISM where what
we did was we kind of constructed a DTMC
of the state transitions of an agent in
PMDP and then exported that to PRISM
where we could verify properties. So,
this was the
of all the kind of
conceptualized properties we could
specify, which was say it was kind of
harder to do it for belief propagation
and finding the minimum free energy
based on the
constraints of PRISM,
but kind of going back to
the this idea where um reachability,
we could represent a DTMC by kind of
and answering that reachability property
of does the agent reach preferred state
with sufficient probability by using
this kind of DTMC construction method.
Where um we could then so long as we
correctly encoded where the end goal
state was, we could kind of
kind of formulate that uh DTMC and put
it in Prism where Prism could then carry
out the relevant
uh calculations to compute that.
So,
uh now is probably the time where I can
kind of go into a demo uh and hopefully
I can further kind of
kind of ground some of the concepts we
talked about. So, excuse me. I hope I
don't awkwardly kind of uh stop sharing
and moving, but I will bring up my
screen.
Okay.
So,
Prism has a kind of a GUI that we
that is kind of the main interface for
using the the Prism engine to carry out
the verification engines. So, when we
talked about a previous kind of Prism
having its own reactive module language
for encoding systems, we um
this is it. This is uh
So, this instant is a 5 by 5 grid. So,
to in our research, we kind of analyzed
several different kind of grid spaces.
So, we went from 5 by 5 to 7 by 7 to 9
by 9. So, when we say that for smaller
state spaces, Prism could accurately
compute something, we were kind of
thinking of it in this way. So, a 5 by 5
grid uh can go up to 9 by 9 grid.
That kind of causes a different
permutation of more complicated states
and spaces.
So, we can see here Prism kind of
encodes observations. So, uh this is the
target where it started. There's the
concept of there being like an up down,
in this case, north south,
east west where I'm
>> [clears throat]
>> But uh the next thing is to kind of talk
about how we run the active inference
experiments. So, I set up this
Python-based environment.
So,
I kind of devised this by kind of
defining a a an active inference agent.
So,
we have a set of parameters that kind of
correspond to what we want how we want
to kind of use set up the environment
for a certain way. So, in this case um
this one DTM C verification 7 x 7.
If we wanted to use Yeah, 7 x 7 grids,
the the program would just see that,
create the environment um
and it wants to find a certain certain
important terminal states. So, in this
case, the goal, trap states um
where we can kind of further instantiate
safety properties, we could put them
here. Um
kind of
uh and then
and then and therefore if you know, we
have kind of other important
configurations like we mentioned the
degree of gal of alpha and gamma, we can
kind of define permutations of these.
And
how it links to the pymdp module is with
the active inference agent. So, here we
can kind of define the relevant learning
models, that being the and the kind of
transition matrices here where
we could kind of further define the
relevant parameters.
And then, this would be
kind of carried out in this in the act
in another class, which is the active
inference experiment class, which would
just perform the active inference runs.
And then, actually save the results in
our results tab.
The final thing is to talk about how we
calculated the DTMC kind of
conceptualization.
What we did
with all the results we calculated in
the experiment run, we had this simple
Jupiter model
model to kind of collect all the results
and output them in a nice way.
This still holds kind of the important
the actual experiments or runs we ran in
2025. So,
based on the certain
configurations, you say we had a long
policy, so that might be something like
five time steps
with a certain kind of configuration of
gamma and alpha values. We would
calculate the relevant values here.
Um,
so,
with like peak memory value and short
time value, this would output in like a
latex friendly format the output values.
I can show the the tables that we
produced in our experiments briefly in
the original paper.
>> [clears throat]
>> Kind of going to the DTMC part,
what would happen is
when an experiment had finished, we
would produce something a dictionary
coding like this. So,
this would be the the kind of cases of
how many times the state transitions
went from a certain state. So, eight say
like
the 0 0 index like the top left all the
way to the bottom, which might be 8 8.
We could encode the trend the
probabilities of an agent transitioning
from each state to another state. So,
and this was
where
what would we then do is we'd had custom
functionality to
take this and produce a PRISM file that
we could then input into the relevant
uh
the uh
into into PRISM.
So, it kind of helped prepare this
beforehand uh before the presentation.
We can kind of see an example of what
that might look like.
I only ran this for about 50 time steps,
but you can see it's kind of being
translated into the PRISM kind of
reactive modeling format where we have
certain probabilities of reaching
certain states. So, we can see for fifth
state, the
for going to like the fourth index
state, there's a 50% chance of going
that from a complete based on the
experimental runs.
And um we could then
so long as we actually encoded where the
reward was or where say terminal state
was, we could put this into PRISM where
it could run
uh kind of in a similar way. We could
specify properties and make sure that
these were like conceptualized.
Um I will go back to my
I think first what I'll do is I can I
can kind of show some results the
experiment. So,
for uh when we did these runs, we
we kind of ran through a lot of
permutations of
yeah, of cost.
So,
these are examples of the runs we did
with PiMDP. So,
we
uh we kind of highlighted kind of the
important cases and the important
outputs uh
as how optimal they were. So, obviously,
whatever kind of configuration achieved
the highest episodes, uh
we kind of highlighted here, for
example,
where um we can see that
uh for this configuration where it had
very high values of alpha, very high
values of gamma. So, they could
potentially be seen as kind of
conflictory cuz the more kind of
exploratory parameters are low
gamma and high alpha, and the opposite
of being more deterministic are say high
gamma and low alpha. Um we kind of uh
analyzed certain outputs of of those.
I think um
we uh we didn't We tried obviously this
being research. We We were just very
curious to see what based on the kind of
the active inference kind of formulation
of how these parameters are supposed to
impact the behavior of active inference
agents, we were it was very kind of
insightful to see what kind of worked
and what didn't work in this case.
Uh we can kind of see an example for how
Prism
So, when we're
when we're talking about uh kind of
Prism being brute force,
we can kind of see here with the grid
resolution, which allowed us to kind of
control the degree of specification of
the belief states.
Grid points kind of directly corresponds
to just how many belief states there
were
uh overall to represent of states. So,
we can see here for 20 foot a grid
resolution of 24, we used 2 million kind
of unique belief states to for each
state space
um
where we could see that as the good
resolution increased the relative error
of the approximation method would
decrease. So, we can see here by the end
uh when a very high good resolution the
under approximation equaled the over
approximation.
It just took quite a lot of time.
But, the downside of this is when we for
the higher more complicated state spaces
as it's brute force it's going to have
more and more good points needs to
calculate for ever increasing good
resolutions. So, for the case of a good
resolution of six
there's a it takes more time for the 7
by 7 grids and there's a a kind of a
slightly bigger
uh relative error between the under
approximation and the over
approximation.
And then when the cases of the 9 by 9
grid obviously that the time it would
take would just get so long um it kind
of very much shows the faults of the
prison approach where it would just take
there's very much problem with the kind
of computational approach in using brute
force which
active inference in a similar case
didn't have. So, as we can see here for
the 9 by 9 grids we could see that for
certain configurations
uh it could run
uh
that
with there being the obvious downside
that these are not
it's not brute force obviously so
again depending on how you
if um if we were to run these
experiments again we could get slightly
different results as it's um as it's
based on the variational
approach of of active inference.
The uh the kind of final set of results
that kind of good to showcase are that
of the verification. So
we um
in our experimental runs we include
cases where there is a trap and where
there is a goal.
And I guess based on the premise of um
using grids as being a kind of
a kind of good a kind of good
abstraction of how a given agent might
kind of conceptualize
you know, interacting with an
environment and trying to solve it.
We could we kind of found some very
interesting findings with how
the
yeah, how how certain parameters kind of
resulted in
you know, what was higher more
probabilistic reachability goals. So,
the important metric to analyze in this
case could be seen here with a
probability. So, we define the property
what was the probability of an active
inference agent not going into trap
whilst reaching the goal for
the the certain amount of episodes it
ran.
So, we found that the best performing
case in this case was when there was
like a balanced
uh
you could say the kind of
there was a balance of the alpha and
gamma values where
it was kind of both the middle values
that we used, which was 16 in this case
where um
I think
what was quite interesting as you can
see here was the active inference agent
that could
to the highest probability could reach
the goal state without going to the trap
state, it's had a
the for the previous episodes that made
up that it actually was in the trap it
actually kind of ended up going to the
trap final state 11 times and the goal
state eight times, which
kind of shows that I guess to kind of
verify
kind of degrees of reaching and
achieving its rewards, it kind of had to
have some degree of experience of
failing and going to the trap state,
which I thought was kind of a very
quite a noticeable insightful thing
about uh
you know, verifying properties, where we
see that um
for the case where
the agent um had a lower chance of
ignoring trap and going to the goal um
based on having like a very a relatively
low alpha and gamma value, it um
it kind of may have gone to the the goal
with less than the trap. Or another
interesting case was we could kind of
verify with a higher
we could
for the agent with a a low a low alpha
and a high kind of gamma parameter, we
could there was a slightly smaller
probability of reaching the goal and
ending in the trap than there was for a
different kind of parameter value. So,
the kind of the kind of hyperparameter
instantiation of an active inference
agent where it should be more precise
with kind of minimizing the free energy
and not exploring at a slightly smaller
probability of kind of
verifying its kind of its reachability
goals here, which uh despite
kind of getting more
having more instantiations of achieving
the goals and less and less
instantiations of
getting into the the kind of trap
terminal state.
Um
But, that kind of
I can
kind of finish on the the remaining
slides of of the presentation.
Uh let me find
I need to go
Yep.
And
does everyone see that okay?
Great.
So, yeah, as um
kind of formally annotating the the
final results we saw for the performance
results.
For small state spaces, uh Prism
outperforms active inference for the 5
by 5, so it can kind of
with very well
in this case with relative error zero,
but it can kind of guarantee reach the
minimum number of steps to reach the
goal. However, for larger state spaces,
that kind of starts to falter.
However, for active inference, we found
that for kind of stochastic
configurations, so this may be ones with
higher alpha values and lower gamma
values, the the path choice worked to
not differ for the small state spaces.
Um the highest absolute count in this
case was 19 for 5.5 minutes.
Where um we found
in this case that kind of more extreme
configurations of
you know, how habitual the active
inferent the active inference agent was
when we
not optimizing its expected free energy
and kind of
in combination with being very
exploratory worked best for solving the
the grid spaces. So
this uh this may be just because there's
in the state spaces there's just a lack
of information in the grids. It's just
very much a grid. There's maybe less
kind of things to consider where say
maybe runs where
uh more balanced would kind of work with
kind of help.
But we can we can kind of see this in
the case of verification where when we
introduced kind of the idea of there
being a trap where there's kind of a an
aspect of safety in trying to reach the
terminal state, um
large gamma and low alpha kind of
generally worked best where we saw that
previous case where a kind of mixed
approach of having a the kind of the
medium value of gamma and the medium
value of alpha
uh led to the highest probability of
reaching the goal and ignoring error.
And in this case, it was the wrong what
was one where it was 16 by 16, uh which
had a 79% chance of reaching the goal
like ignoring the error.
So this this kind of leads us to the
conclusion. So Prism very effective for
small state spaces. This and the
reliability diminishes as state spaces
kind of increase. These were kind of
more links to kind of computate
computational complexity kind of goes of
this research. Whilst for active
inference for the case of just solving
these computational problems, extreme
configurations perform the best and
there is promise for the verification
research, I guess, with this and how we
verified the the properties and as DTMCs
in Prism.
So kind of going to the future
directions. So I think one thing that's
very important to highlight was we ran
these experiments pre-pymdp
1.0.0
and
what pymdp, the latest kind of build of
pymdp does is it kind of supports great
support for
variational message passing schemes. It
has kind of more has added a lot more
sophistication to how we can kind of
um as the VMPs kind of a more
neurobiologically accurate version of
how
active inference may do inference as
opposed to FPI, that would be something
that would be kind of very important to
do in a say if there was more work to be
done. Um
and there's also just things that be
there being more large time steps, more
fine-tuning parameters could be done to
kind of get very
kind of better exactly results.
Um there could be more scenarios. So we
just had very simple grids, but we could
have kind of game theory implications.
How does How do these How can we kind of
compare say how
Prism might formulate stochastic games
with say active inference with having
multiple agents Um and we could even
include more research with other kind of
different
approaches. So, compare what was done
with reinforcement learning in previous
papers with active inference in Prism.
So,
the big kind of future direction for
this is
a problem that formal method check
Ideally, what we would have liked to
have had is we could have kind of create
active inference systems in Prism and
verify certain properties with that, but
the lack of support for kind of
important calculations like nabla and
soft max kind of mean we'd have to make
caveats.
They're kind of This is kind of
I think according to the research, this
is not only just apparent in active
inference, but there is a lot of
research kind of going into other fields
like artificial intelligence with neural
networks, which could kind of also
potentially support this. So, there is
definitely kind of, you know, either
potential for like
extending Prism to support these
operations or there being a new tool.
There's a
At least I remember
researching upon the tool say like
Marabou, which is not necessarily
a probabilistic model checker.
Uh
I mean at least my understanding, but it
kind of is a case of a formal methods
tool that supports these operations.
Um and there could be kind of further
kind of computational complexity
analysis with
um
with how we can kind of analyze expected
free energy. So, the example is
in the same way we could have a very
understand kind of how expected free
energy can competition the competition
complexity of how it kind of solves
things such as kind of having a deep
dive.
That
um for that uh that kind of finishes
on my on my slides and on my
presentation. Uh
but I'm I'm happy to answer questions or
uh yeah, kind of
go into depth from there. But that um
that finishes everything.
>> Great.
Thank you. Getting, do you want to
begin with any comments or I can ask?
>> Uh if you just uh
it's fine just to have the questions,
why not?
>> Yeah, so in in your experience working
with Prism with other systems, what
kinds of takeaways does a formal
verification bring? Like what insights
do you get after this type of system
that we wouldn't be able to make before
through some kind of just empirical
simulation-based
approach? And like how do you think that
can
be valuable for the situations people
are doing active inference modeling in?
>> So, I can say something here just
the initial idea that James had was to
actually give formal uh guarantees that
the results from active
uh inference sort of met some
like guarantees. Now, if you run uh
simulations, then you
then you can get sort of you can get a
sort of a
like result, but it's it's it's it's not
guaranteed to be like correct. The idea
in sort of formal like methods is that
we explore everything and we get a a
like precise answer. So, the initial aim
was to actually formally
like verify active
uh inference, but that proved to be too
much to do for a fifth-year
undergrad um undergraduate
uh student. So, it's like again, so what
we ended up doing instead was what James
talked about, which was like comparing
the two different
like approaches. So, James, do you have
anything that you want to add there?
>> Um no, um I think yeah, I kind of
that's to yeah, I'm not sure. But
>> Like in in a in a mobility
setting, some grid world-like setting,
um what kinds of takeaways would would
would we want to reach? Like I guess it
was just where where
I was wondering. And then also another
uh
question is you you talked about the
reward
or cost constraint structure
and the reachability analysis
and how was learning or epistemic value
accounted for?
>> So,
I think uh
I one thing to add to like future
directions is I think kind of based on
uh the kind of the time I had, I
couldn't kind of So,
I would have been nice to have kind of
analyzed uh changes in like belief
states and the kind of referring to like
the the second part of your question
there. So, uh I think ideally what I
would do next time is I could kind of
analyze say how the
how the belief states kind of changed
and like how that learning was applied.
There could be hopefully some kind of
hope where in the same way I constructed
like a a DTMC of state transitions and
uh in the runs of active inference,
there could have been something similar
done to the the kind of act the actual
which kind of how belief states would
kind of would changed
or how they changed in that, if that
makes sense, um based on
which um
would be kind of future work on that. Uh
a simple case like I just I just
couldn't I just ran out of time to kind
of
analyze those
that kind of aspect of like how active
how we could analyze like the learning
process in in prism or uh
or the of active inference.
Um
May I ask for the first part of your
question, is that just
just
kind of more what are more of kind of
properties I'd say to kind of
um that we could kind of get in in grid
worlds. Does that kind of allude to the
first part of your question?
>> Yeah.
Yeah, like whether it's performance,
reliability, or security, what what
types of claims can can be layered onto
existing
models, and how can like the value
proposition of formal methods be brought
into the computational simulation
setting
where people may not be familiar with
those methods, but I think if it's
clear enough how and why they matter,
then they will be adopted.
>> So, um
I suppose there's always
I guess there's always going to be the
caveat where there's just going to be
downsides to how
the limits of kind of of grid world
spaces
where and what we can kind of
cuz obviously ideally it would be nice
in an ideal world if we could have like
all the state spaces in the world where
we could um
I guess kind of create more
uh specific and specific environments. I
think
I um
I would probably ideally I
I would like to kind of kind of research
more into the
kind of the neurobiological side of
where of kind of how active inference
kind of
Um I know there's like the two bandit
problem where it kind of analyzes
uh a lot of the research focuses on how
it kind of
um
it just uses that kind of simplification
of like a kind of state space to kind of
analyze how how active inference kind of
makes decisions.
Uh
It's just I've I think the the the I
guess
it's very much kind of playing on the
basis that active inference has a kind
of hierarchical
um
state space.
Uh You know where there's kind of
numerous kind of layers of different
active inference
um maybe agents isn't the right word um
and how it kind of gradually builds up
and kind of infer from smaller state
spaces
uh would be another kind of thing
to kind of add to that. Um
at least
the kind of
based on the kind of constraints of the
of what we could do with certain state
space sizes um
if
if a if a kind of grid world's just like
a very good kind of abstraction of just
problem solving where it has to kind of
consider certain parameters of how
active inference may have certain
constraints on how like the temporal
depth of the policies are or certain
kind of
configurations and how it uses alpha and
gamma. These kind of
at least what prism or the research I
hope would show is that
uh
you know different we can kind of we can
use prism to kind of see the chance of
you know higher chances of kind of
success and less chance of failure. I
think
um
kind of going back to the
at least this result in that case where
if a kind of grid world is a is a good
abstraction of kind of
uh of kind of state spaces which active
inference will could employ different
sets of hyper parameters to solve
in the case where we saw where a kind of
mixed the kind of middle kind of period
of
uh alpha of having kind of middle values
of alpha and gamma being
uh resulted in
higher higher problem a higher
probability of success in this case kind
of shows that
that kind of verifies potential ideas in
active inference where like
if an active inference agent's too
exploratory or if it's too if it's too
focused on
uh
via the alpha parameter or in the case
of gamma precision where it's it's too
focused on minimizing free energy how
that actually impacts and kind of
showcases how
um that you know verify kind of features
of of active inference in that case and
I think at least um
in the case where we found that where
there's like environments where there's
a kind of
an abstracted goal state and and like in
the case of there being a terminal state
we could kind of show
uh
kind of map onto like the ideas of how
active inference wants to kind of um
aims to kind of
actually describe kind of neuro
neurobiological behavior with um
uh at least this was at least somewhat
of a good attempt to kind of kind of add
add to that I suppose if that makes that
makes sense.
>> Yes, I think we have many different
threads intersecting with uh empirical
and biological sort of philosophical and
system scientific conceptual and then
this
connection that your work
shows both sides of with the maths and
the computer science
and how we can have a simulation that
may have some interesting formal
properties that we might never be able
to find
except through basically axiomatic
analysis.
>> Yeah.
>> Or exhaustive search. But as you're
showing exhaustive search even in very
simple generative models is going to
quickly become infeasible.
So
building intuition through exhaustive
search in small models
and seeking to understand how these
strongly typed axiomatic approaches can
bring interpretability to models is
really exciting. So, if you have any
either of you
other comments or anything else you want
to share, please go for it.
>> Um
I have a student Sorry, but I'll I'll be
back now.
All right. I think
maybe
Uh
I'll let Gavin. But I think I'm I'm I'm
okay for um
for uh yeah. Uh yeah.
Sorry. I I I have a
student that was coming at half at half
past. So, but James. So
all that I want to
it's sort of
What's being used here is very much just
a
a prototype. So, it was developed um
about
uh quite a while ago now as part of
Google Summer of Code
that
that project. And it was just through
that this like prototype for a POMDPs
was
like developed. So, we've got sort of
more advanced techniques for standard
MDPs and also
stochastic games. But there is a chance
to sort of
improve the start efficiency in sort of
the POMDP case, but there will still be
like the limit. We will be able to go We
could if there was more time spent on
like the implementation going like
larger, but not that much as it's a very
difficult like problem to solve.
>> Great.
>> Okay.
Thank you, fellows.
>> Um
>> Let let me know if there's any more
links or anything to add to the video
description so people can find the work.
Otherwise, thank you again for joining.
See you later.
>> Uh thank you so much.
>> All right.